[Music]
country music superstar Luke Bryan
caught on tape striking a heckler right
in the face now Lucas sold more than 7
million singles but this might be his
biggest hit ever Luke Bryan paused
mid-song step off the stage and there it
is he slapped a concert guard Luke's rep
explained it this way quote a man in the
front row was making crude hand gestures
toward Luke during his performance the
conscious security personnel saw the
man's disruptive actions of the event
and he was escorted out
it happened as Bryan was performing his
song move Wednesday night at the Charlie
Daniels all-star volunteer jam and
national at veteran's fundraiser his rep
said the concert goer quote was
insulting not only to him but more
importantly to the men women and
families sitting around him
it all happened pretty fast but here's a
question could look be charged with a
crime well this morning Nashville police
told us at this point no one has come
forward to file a report
we showed videos of the incident to a
former la prosecutor Michael kraut who
has reviewed similar cases from a public
relations standpoint it's understandable
why Luke did what you did he was
defending the name and the honor the
service meant that the concert was
therefore from a legal standpoint though
in my opinion I think Luke has two
issues here
number one he could be criminally
charged with battery or something
similar to that and from a civil lawsuit
he can lose a lot of money Luke's one
with his right arm so it seems he's all
healed after breaking his right clavicle
in a bike accident in October yeah I
won't ever outgrow being clumsy the
concert slap is a surprise to ET online
senior music editor sophie scholl AC who
spent a lot of time with Luke on the red
carpet and backstage this incident feels
completely out of character for Luke if
you'll recall in the past usually if
he's off the stage it's because he's
fallen and Lucas such a good sport he
always laughs those things off now every
time that I've seen him he's been such a
positive guy he's truly got a great
outlook so for me it feels like I
believe him that he must have been
really offended on behalf of the
military families and veterans that were
in the audience
[Music]
you